oops I'm like struggling tick-tock on
sale everybody my name is Jeff Jeff and
I also have a youtube channel called
cool T where I demonstrate food doubles
for you guys and things like that but
today I'm gonna be reviewing tick tock
food hacks that I think pretty
interesting there's gonna be five of
them today first tick tock food hack
it's gonna be heavy top of Indian
obviously in the tick tack they're
playing cut it by ot Genesis I think
it's perfect for the editor the video
the onion was being sliced vertically
and then horizontally and then turned
over again and sliced down this way to
get some perfect small dice cuts I think
that this pack looks poor I'm really
anxious right so I'm gonna do that right
now I'm gonna show you guys a safer way
to do it just because I don't want you
guys to try the tick tock hack and then
actually cut your fingers off I'm gonna
cut it in half slice down this way and
then I'm going to and then slice down
like this and then awesome beautiful
small diced onion that's like a basic
standard weight good and you know I
learned how to continue hopefully
everybody cut it up in that way not I
find you guys all cut onions that way
make sure you cut the end in half I
don't want any mess on my hands make
sure you guys practice the technique
[Music]
second tick tock I'm very excited about
because I love chasing news I'm making
cookies all the time it's very
interesting because there's no fat
involved no oil no butter no pan you're
gonna do it in the toaster let's try it
out so this into the a hack it's gonna
be interesting
it is done in a toaster which is really
really cool I like the fact that it
doesn't really ask for too much oil so
I'm just going to take the tortilla a
little bit in the middle like this so
it's like in quarters and then I'm going
to pop it in toaster you know my toaster
identity okay
as you can see it's like toasted and the
cheese on the inside is melted that's
interesting
go back I think that this way to do it
it's a little bit hard because you know
when we folded the tortilla all the t's
kind of like stays in one place version
is being all around when you
because you know it's nice and flat
think about it she's like all around
there but yeah I mean I think I should
try that yourselves first I think it's
interesting to do I mean it was a fun
way to do it but I think I'm gonna
continue to make my quesadillas how to
make how to make cheese hey it's pretty
much making ricotta cheese which is just
pretty much milk and some kind of acid
like lemon or vinegar I'm gonna use
lemon juice but today I'll be using
vinegar just have you did it in the
video I am also going to be adding some
salt and pepper some avocados and then I
season great gal in the move it so hot
vinegar some salt and then we're gonna
let this boil and then we're gonna
strain it is now starting to separate
earlier when I showed you guys the
liquid the way it was white still now
it's clear that's pretty much one you
know the third cheese is done so I'm
going to shake it just a little bit more
approve of making ricotta cheese at home
don't think it's a hack a hack is
something to do to make things easier
and life easier ricotta takes some time
to make and I think it's a great way to
make cheese and I think it's a great way
to use your time number four and
sandwich hat okay so this one's cool
because I like sandwiches and I really
like the way she looks really satisfied
and happy at the end of the video so I
want to be like him and I want to eat an
egg sandwich and I want to be happy like
so try it out so here I have a pan
medium heat right now a little bit of
butter two eggs and then season with
salt and pepper just plain simple white
bread flip it over like this come again
on this side that wait I'm confused
oops big dog I fail
now upgraded from this spatula to this
spatula pretty much just hi showed you
guys before I heat up the pan added some
butter add the eggs flip the bread and
get under the bread with the spatula and
then flip it like that and then fold
over the egg on the side so all inside
the piece of bread flip it over like
this one more time like this that's the
second attempt and that's ticked off
egg sandwich pack that's delicious I
actually and I think it's a great hat
because really baby or make a quick
snack quick breakfast on the go lunch on
the go whatever it may be I think this
is a great hack I would definitely try
this flour and now we come to our sit
tick-tock hack in the video pretty much
having a bread soaked into water
wrap it in foil pop it in the oven that
pretty much creates steam which is
obviously a great way to revive and
celebrate because there's a lot of
moisture so I'm invited times out still
pieces bad yet we have here I'm going to
completely soak this in the water in the
sink because that is completely soaked
wrap it in foil and I'm going to place
it in the oven at 300 degrees about 12
minutes it's no longer still and it's
steaming I don't know if you can get
that action right there but it's
steaming turn down attend recommend this
[Music]
alright guys so I definitely enjoy doing
the tic-tock food and I definitely
recommend doing them at home if you guys
have any more tips on food hacks and you
guys would like me to review send them
my way until then
[Music]